la parole est à monsieur eric woerth
pour le groupe l'est républicain
monsieur le premier ministre
dans un pays où la peur de l'avenir
devient un handicap majeur où le chômage
de masse s'installe comme jamais où la
dette plombe la compétitivité et
l'investissement vous réaliser l'exploit
de présenter un budget où il ne se passe
strictement rien rien de bon rien de
fort rien qui puisse répondre aux
gigantesques enjeux auxquels est
confronté notre pays rien qui entraîne
les français vers une autre vision plus
juste plus entreprenants plus innovantes
de la france il ya un deuxième exploit
celui de faire systématiquement moins
bien que les autres pays qui sont nos
principaux partenaires la dépense
publique augmente et le déficit de
l'état ne baisse que de deux petits
milliards le déficit global se réduit à
la vitesse de l'escargot et j'ai le plus
grand doute sur votre capacité à
respecter les 3 3% annoncée en 2016
notamment quand je constate vos
promesses de dépenses nouvelles qui
représente plus de 11 milliards d'euros
plus grave les mesures d'économie
principale concerne le prélèvement
européen et les taux d'intérêt qui sont
des phénomènes extérieurs
sinon vos économies sont des coups de
rabot aveugle et déstabilisant puisque
vous ne réformez pas vous paupérisée
l'administration et les services publics
alors certes vous baisser les impôts
après les avoir tenté tant augmenté en
ce domaine comme dans d'autres les
conventions les convictions du
gouvernement sont fluctuantes
la conséquence c'est un impôt sur le
revenu hyper concentré favorisant l'exil
fiscal et des entreprises toujours plus
inquiètes autres grands chapitres
d'économie les dotations aux
collectivités locales
vous avez délibérément choisi
d'augmenter les impôts locaux c'est
votre responsabilité est un piège que
vous tendez aux collectivités et aux
contribuables
enfin pour la première fois depuis 2008
le nombre de fonctionnaires de l'état va
de nouveau augmenter
c'est une décision ahurissante et à
contresens
ce budget est votre dernière occasion de
nous dire où vous voulez aller
quel chemin doit prendre la france pour
affronter les défis du monde
le chemin que vous avez choisi s'appelle
une impasse pourquoi monsieur le premier
ministre toujours choisir l'absence de
réformes comme solution alors que même
que votre ministre de l'économie chaque
jour nous dit le contraire
merci monsieur woerth la parole est à
monsieur michel sapin
ministres des finances et des comptes
publics merci beaucoup monsieur le
président monsieur eric woerth monsieur
le ministre à des questions budgétaires
vous les connaissez bien
vous les avez vécu et donc vous savez
très bien d'où vient la france puisque
c'est là où vous l'avez laissé avec une
dette considérable avec des déficits
considérables avec des augmentations
d'impôts considérable que c'est un pont
porte sur les entreprises ou qu'ils
portent sur les ménages ces deux-là de
nous partons là où vous nous avez laissé
le budget auquel vous faites allusion
que nous vous présentons que vous aurez
à examiner ici que nous avons examiné en
commission des finances ce matin pour
il a deux caractéristiques que vous avez
rarement atteint monsieur vais première
caractéristique c'est un budget qui se
fonde sur des objectifs qui ont été
atteints l'objectif de croissance pour
2015 1%
il sera atteint l'objectif pour l'année
prochaine de 1,5 pour cent
il est considéré par tous les
observateurs extérieurs comme un
objectif réaliste
la croissance reprend là où vous l'avez
laissée à des niveaux totalement atone
deuxième chose ce budget ces deux
budgets des engagements tenus
nous avons pris des engagements
vis-à-vis des entreprises vous avez
augmenté les taxes sur les entreprises
nous les 10 millions parce qu'il faut
redonner aux entreprises des marges de
manoeuvre pour leur permettre d'investir
et pour leur permettre d'embaucher
c'est nous qui le faisons avec le pacte
de responsabilité qui continuera à être
mises en oeuvre l'année prochaine
engagement tenu vis-à-vis des ménages
puisque vis-à-vis des ménages nous
avions pris l'engagement
la majorité a pris l'engagement de
baisser en deux ans de 5 milliards les
impôts qui pesait sur les ménages pour
beaucoup de ses impôts c'est vous qui
l'aviez décidé c'est vous qui l'aviez
fait augmenter et c'est nous aujourd'hui
qui décidons de rendre aux français une
part des efforts qu'ils ont faits donc
monsieur woerth parfaitement apte à
contrario de ce que vous avez dit ce
budget est clair c'est un budget qui oui
maintient le cap
c'est un budget qui est dommage
des objectifs connus c'est un objet
c'est un budget d'efficacité était un
objet de justice mes chers collègues
vous avez pu constater mais ça y est
c'était vrai pour monsieur woerth
également que le chronomètre ne
fonctionne pas je n'y suis pour rien
mais ne fonctionne pas nous avons nous
avons des ressorts à l'assemblée
nationale et il y avait ici un
fonctionnement plus mécanique dont j'ai
la charge et je vais le faire de façon
très rigoureuse
la parole est un